first of all I want to thank Wes thank
John Milt uh Griff you know I appreciate
you guys making this happen obviously
I've you know spent my entire career in
Portland 11 years a long time so I
am extremely thankful for that
organization that City the fans
for giving me the kind of experience
that I had and you know I don't think
it's a secret
how much I want to win and that's how we
got here today and I think they want to
win equally as bad as I do and you know
I couldn't be more excited I couldn't be
more thankful
for this opportunity to be a part of
this organization to play alongside
the best player in the league you know
um you know it's going to be fun and uh
the hospitality that they show my family
we touched down to a parade
my first time getting traded and so you
don't know what to expect you know so to
walk in to something like that was
special it was a great welcoming and um
you know it's it's something that I
really appreciated
and it only made me more excited to be
here and more excited to get to work so
you know I'm thankful
yeah about 5 000 attended
um you got a good taste of hospitality
here in Milwaukee in the state of
Wisconsin
let's go with Eric with the first
question
hey Damian Eric named the athletic nice
to meet you welcome walkie um I'm
curious just how have you processed the
last five days like just the idea of you
mentioned getting traded for the first
time now being in this situation just
can you take us through the emotions of
of all of that
yeah it was it was definitely a
different experience
you know I was just kind of sitting
there in my man cave I didn't really
know what was going to happen I started
to think like man it might get the
training camp and I might just be
sitting and waiting you know
um
and then I got that call
for my agent it was like man you you're
getting traded to Milwaukee
and I had heard so many different things
that I was like you know
am I really getting traded and he was
like yeah they traded you and I can tell
in the seriousness in his voice that it
was it was real
and um he was like I'll let you sit with
it for a while you know I'll call you
back I'm gonna settle some things and
then we'll talk about it
and um after we got off the phone I sat
there and I was like
you know I'm really I'm really moving on
and it became reality for me and I kind
of just started to think like my entire
family is here
um how am I gonna pack everything up you
know I started to panic a little bit
like it's you know first time
and then I wanted to you know let my
family know so I started walking around
the house and like nobody was there you
know everybody was out doing something
I'm calling people nobody picking up the
phone
I was like man any other time I'll be
able to reach whoever I need to so
um I had to sit with it by myself for a
while so when that happened I just kind
of went back to the man cave and I sat
there
and then that was when the call started
coming in my friends you know family
members like you know is it real is it
true
and then I started to think about the
team you know so
it was like who did I get traded for you
know how like who's going to be there
and then I looked it up and uh you know
I saw what kind of team I was coming to
be a part of and then I was when the
excitement kicked in you know just
recognizing the opportunity uh that it
is and
um just knowing how much I I want to win
and going into every season uh being
optimistic and thinking that we got a
chance to get it done and then coming
into this situation
and knowing that you got an opportunity
to do it uh the excitement definitely
kicked in when I when I sat with it for
a little bit Jim Jim lozarski Milwaukee
Journal Sentinel welcome Dave
um
when and and why did Milwaukee
I guess pop up for you as a potential
place to go like when did you maybe
think about that and why did that become
a place that you were like okay this I'd
be comfortable going there uh it was I
would say
maybe two weeks ago
you know it was just all this talk and
you know all these things and it was a
lot of things said that that didn't come
from me you know I hadn't spoke on the
situation a whole lot
but uh as we got into it my agent called
me and he was just like you know what
about Milwaukee and obviously Giannis
you know is his public record that I've
always mentioned you know if I had to
team up with one person it would be him
so when we talked about it I was like um
I would definitely be interested in that
um obviously
and he was just like okay you know and I
could tell he kind of put it in his back
pocket and obviously in these situations
you don't you never control completely
you know how things end up or where you
end up going
so um
you know it came about and you know it
was an option and it was like you know
press play you know why why not why pass
up on that type of opportunity
um so you know it was something that
came up I would say two weeks ago and I
was interested in that for sure and now
that we're here
I'm excited for this opportunity
fence
damn you brought it up earlier playing
with Giannis Mexico or Yahoo sports
sorry about that
you're in a situation where you said
publicly you said to Chris I'm going to
a situation where I'm not the best
player yeah but at the same time you can
have the ball in your hands the last two
or three minutes of the game is that
something that appealed to you that sort
of situation where you don't have to
carry but you can still be yourself
yeah I mean I'ma always be myself you
know
um
and being myself doesn't always mean
that you know I got to be out front or
everything has to be about me I think
because of who I am as a person
uh the way that I prepare myself the way
that I approach the game
um I'm gonna find a way to have an
impact and like I said playing with
somebody like Giannis he's gonna the
kind of attention that he's gonna get
is only going to make the game easier
and more simple for me and I think
because of the way that I impose myself
when I do play and how I how I attack
games
he's going to have a kind of opportunity
that I think he hasn't had as well so
um
I mean the best thing I could tell you
is how how exciting it's going to be how
excited I am
um and that I'm prepared for it you know
I don't
I don't go into any situation expecting
to you know for things to be about me
um so I see I know the player that he is
I know the player that I am
um and I know how to make my presence
felt regardless of
um the role you know it's not the same
as this level but when I was in college
I walked into a situation
where it was you know upperclassmen
seniors that were like have been there a
couple years they have been established
they were known around our our
conference and I stepped in and I didn't
step on nobody's toes but I announced my
presence and I announced myself and did
what I had to do
it was the same when I got to Portland
you know La was an All-Star
you know Wes was a vocal presence Batoon
was like the same
and I stepped in and announced my
presence and I was while understanding
that I'm playing with LaMarcus Aldridge
but he also needs me
to be who I am you know for us to be our
our full selves and our best selves as a
team so I think this is similar to that
except I'm older you know my
understanding of it is even better
uh you know and I think I'm the best
version of myself as a player as well so
I think we'll complement each other
really well
and um
you know I think he's the kind of guy
that he's not going into it worried
about being a man or anything like that
either so I think it'll work out
perfectly
as we continue just a reminder name and
affiliation before you ask your question
Jack go ahead how's it going Damien uh
Jack Mooney CBS Sports a little bit
specifically on that partnership with
Giannis you're one of the best pick and
roll guys in the league it's pretty easy
to Envision that sort of partnership
have you thought about that possibility
and just what sort of impact you two can
have specifically on the pick and roll
yeah I think it's
uh obviously I'm a pick and roll player
I've played a lot of pick and roll in my
career
and when I think about playing with him
I just I'll just try to figure out how
do you defend it you know I haven't
played against a lot of coverages where
teams aren't at the level of the screen
whether it's showing trapping or just
being there to where I got to get a ball
up and I just
I can't imagine them wanting him to have
the ball you know at the free-throw line
coming downhill with an advantage and
Chris on the wing and Brooke you know
you got really good players out there so
um I've definitely thought about it and
I just don't know how you you know how
you handle that and I think it's going
to be something that that teams have to
put up with and try to figure out
but I'm excited you know I think it's
going to be a lot of opportunity for me
out there because of who he is and vice
versa
Chris
Hayes TNT NBA TV bleacher a Dame now
that this move is made
what they laughing at man I have no idea
man
a damn now at this move his move has
been made this summer was the first time
you were working out and not knowing
where you were going to be who are you
working out for how were you able to
prepare and like because because you
know years prior you're working out with
a purpose because you know the system
how are you able to prepare yourself for
the unknown
um I just try not to think about it too
much you know I didn't put pressure on
myself
um about all work what system am I gonna
play in where am I going to be like I
said before I know if I show up prepared
and I show up as myself
um I'm gonna figure it out you know I
had that type of confidence in myself in
whatever situation but
um I think it was just a summer for me
where I made my shrimps stronger you
know I kept them as my shrimps and then
the things that I felt like I need to
tighten up and sharpen up
um I took the time to do those things
but I think at this stage of my career
I'm I am who I'm gonna be you know it's
just a matter of how well I can take
care of myself
um you know how sharp I can be and you
know just whatever that situation was
just being able to get my feet on the
ground and then start you know locking
into it and understand what what our
purpose is what's expected of me what
what kind of basketball we gonna play
what what kind of personnel are we going
to have and
um I think coming into this situation is
very very easy you know you look at
somebody like Giannis you look at Chris
you look at Brooke you look you know
when I looked at the roster it was very
easy for me to make sense of you know
what my job is going to be
move over to the side Gabe
gibson.com welcome to Milwaukee team
appreciate it just curious you've been
here a few days what if your initial
impression spin about the team chemistry
and the culture and whatnot and how do
you see that evolving
uh I I mean as far as team chemistry
might check I'm a rapper too so yeah
check them
right away that it was a family
environment
I could tell that it was a family
environment right away uh
and just a humble environment you know
everybody was just chill it was real
calm
uh and I I think when it comes to
chemistry you don't really know until
you get out there on the floor and you
know stuff started happening you know
somebody just missed while they open
somebody's not playing you know things
got to happen for you to understand like
where where does this this team really
stand you know how the chemistry really
is and
um just looking at the personalities
that I've seen so far it seems like that
won't be an issue you know I think it'll
be pretty good chemistry
um but as far as the the city like the
being embraced like that you know it
definitely makes you comfortable a lot
faster when you see that you're wanted
and people are excited about you you
being here
um and I like I said man I A lot of it
was unexpected I didn't know what to
expect
um
you know it's been a great couple days
you know my family's been really
comfortable
um you know I've gotten some work in you
know I've been around a little bit so
I'm excited man I every time I've been
to Milwaukee over the course of my
career I just stay in the hotel the
whole time because it's like snowing or
something like that so
um seeing the Sun out and you know being
by the water and stuff like that it
almost
um you know made me smile a little bit
like man this this could be all right
you know what I'm saying every time I
came here it was snowing you know it was
like depression a little bit so
uh
uh you know I'm excited to be here man
you know like I said seeing an
opportunity basketball wise and you know
seeing the type of environment that
they've created
the type of success that they've had and
knowing that I could bring something
um that could get us over the hump and
have the opportunity to win
I'm definitely excited to be here and
it's been a great experience so far
Dame Jamal Collier from ESPN uh welcome
again to Milwaukee uh kind of just
coming off that like you talked about
one and obviously to win and winning in
your career and you come into a
situation where you know you and Giannis
together championship and stuff is the
expectation just kind of curious how you
sort of approach uh how are you looking
at that how are you coming into this
season are you excited about the
opportunity to kind of show you
obviously in the playoffs and seen on
that level but in that way and
especially also kind of considering the
other teams in the East Boston just made
a trade how do you feel about just the
competition level there
I mean I think initially is the
competition level is is always extremely
high obviously you you have the
the media they look at you know this guy
went to this team this guy went to that
team and those things jump off the page
but
um you just never know what can happen
with with injuries and you know guys
break out some teams are better than you
expect like Denver won a championship
last year you know nobody jumped out and
said that last season it was all the you
know the teams that looked better on
paper
so um for me I think I'm I'm approaching
this season like
just doing the work you know obviously I
in my career my life I've never been
a part of any situation that was that
was not an underdog you know from my AAU
program I played for my neighborhood AAU
program I went to Weber State
I get drafted to Portland like you know
I've done a lot more overachieving in my
career than like living up to it you
know what was expected so I'm excited
about that I think once again
uh at at my age and at this stage in my
career you know I think it came at the
perfect time because I'm prepared for
you know a situation like this
um and Giannis and I spoke and it was
you know the the I think the focal point
of that conversation was just that
yes it looks good you know and it's a
it's an attractive thing me and him
playing together the kind of team that
we have but
the work has to get done and you know I
think that's one thing that we're
extremely like-minded about
um that I've learned in the last couple
days is like I
when it comes to you know having some
success I'm a person that wants to get
in the mud and make sure that I'm doing
the things that's going you know earn us
that right you know to have that type of
success and he is too so
um it made me feel good to know that he
thinks that way you know because I
almost get a little bit nervous about
people around the situation having
expectations and you know how the people
that's involved in it are going to carry
it so we got on the same page about that
right away so I think that's that's the
approach
Dame Daria Melendez WISN welcome to
Milwaukee uh you kind of mentioned a
little bit entering your past training
camps
player Personnel question system
question you're coming in now you're
playing with a bona fide Superstar for
the first time really in your career and
no offense to CJ Lamarcus but that's got
to be refreshing right yeah it is I mean
I know people always say I'm excited but
I'm really excited you know like it's my
whole career has been
off the dribble threes pick and roll
pull up threes contested you know double
team trapped and
I'm just curious to see how that's how
how that can be possible with a player
as dominant as he is
um you know I'm excited I'm excited for
the opportunity to play with them I'm
excited for the opportunity to to be
freed up and to be able to you know
um have more space and opportunity to to
play
uh so it's gonna be fun man this
um as far as the system
um you know I know my my coach of my
first nine years of my career is on this
staff as well Terry Stotts and we joked
a little bit you know when I ran into
him about some of the the sets that you
know is going to be put in so I was like
cool you know uh I think it's gonna be a
good time but to answer your question
playing next to Giannis is going to be
um a great opportunity opportunity that
I've never had before and uh once again
where I'm at right now I think it came
at the perfect time
uh Steve aspener nba.com
um you know Drew holiday's reputation as
a Defender yeah
um
what has your approach been to that side
of the ball and now that you're going to
be in his spot do you see that
necessarily changing for you at all
um I think
when you come into the NBA you know
especially
as a young player that plays a lot I
think the place where you struggle the
most is on the defensive end of the
floor and um
I don't think it's always a lack of
Desire I think it's just not knowing
terminology sometimes you just running
around like a chicken with your head cut
off you don't know what to expect you
don't know Tendencies You Don't Know
personnel
um and I think if you you know really
take a look into my progression
defensively you'll see that I've gotten
better year after year after year after
year even if you look into it the last
couple seasons
and I think the main reason for that is
understanding what's going on I know
players around the league I understand
calls when I hear a call gets called out
we all run the same types of actions we
all use the same terminology so I'm able
to be ahead of it and understand what's
happening
um also playing on a defensive minded
team this year
um I think it'll make it more simple
like coach Griff was saying I understand
where to be on the floor I understand
how to rotate I understand how to play
Team defense but I'm a competitor
and uh at the very least on that end of
the floor I'm gonna compete you know I'm
not gonna come in here and beat you
holiday I think in my personal opinion I
think he's the best defender on the
perimeter
um but it's it's gonna be it's not gonna
be what people just throw out there
Loosely you know I think is
um in the past has been something where
people just say oh damn you know on
defense he's this on offense but
um you know the people that I play
against to tell you like I'm I ain't a
pushover you know what I'm saying and
I've also had a lot of responsibility on
the offensive end for my entire career
and I think playing with the kind of
players I'll be playing with here it'll
also give me an opportunity to you know
show myself much better on the defensive
end of the floor
uh Scott grosski CBS Milwaukee uh
obviously we've talked a lot about you
and Giannis some of the other key guys
on this team how do you see yourself
fitting in with guys like Chris Brooke
obviously you've played with Pat before
as well
um I think it's I'm familiar with with
the way they play I think that's the
best best way to tell you is
uh offensively I'm gonna make the right
play
um once we get on the floor I I think I
pick up
um things pretty quickly you know I see
what guys like to do I see how I can fit
myself in you know with the guys around
me I've always done that and I don't
think this would be any different you
know but it's nothing that I can tell
you specifically I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that I just know how to react
to what's going on around me and once we
get on the floor
um you know I'll find my spots and I'll
find my spaces to where I gotta you know
be myself but how I can be you know a
compliment to those guys as well
hi Dave Dylan Hunter Carter WTMJ radio
welcome to Milwaukee appreciate it
you've become known throughout the
league for you know finding a small
Market team and making that a home for
10 years and that's something I know you
uh are very proud of as well so what is
the experience like for you to now enter
a different small market and kind of go
through that process again where do you
even start
um I think it's uh uh it just feels
familiar you know it doesn't feel like a
a crazy environment you know it's like I
I left one small Market to another one
and
um one thing I can say is the people
that I went to work with every day in
Portland are what made that environment
one that I felt comfortable making home
you know for as long as I did
and I think the fact that this feels
similar you know you come in here
everybody's like family everybody's cool
everybody's around each other they hang
out here
um you know that's the type of
environment that I've known my entire
career so I think it'll only make it
easier and you know more comfortable
transition
foreign